okay alright so this is a meeting that
is one in a series about integrating SQL
database capabilities and SQL databases
and too often language we've had some
integration of these things for like
decades but this is a tighter
integration into a full with a full
symbolic representation of everything so
let's get started where are we starting
here are we starting on the entity
algebra stuff or are we starting on the
demo into the intro we're not gonna
start with a demo no no I'd rather keep
the demo for later if you really need it
but I'd love to see a demo okay hmm what
why don't we okay we can start um
[Music]
okay let's sum well shoot should we
start with that
we start with the demo your choice
algebra okay special all right yeah fine
okay so this is an entity store this is
our typical entity store form the outer
level is types the next level down is
entities and the next level down is the
properties of each entity and their
values correct yes okay so now what is
this would be equivalent to
you
I'm now confused here I see this is this
is a pure multi-level I don't understand
how you disambiguate these cases what if
you understand what I'm saying I mean in
other words within an entity store
you're saying that you require this
structure with explicit types labels and
explicit entities labels here yeah it's
because because types can
types can prompt sub properties and keys
can I'm aware I'm aware and well but I
mean that the sub properties go here
when there's types there where the sub
properties go so there are sub there are
properties that are global that go along
the types properties there are for a
single type go along entities and
properties and so on okay so each one of
these then has each type has an entity's
key a property's key and potentially
other metadata associated with that type
exactly okay the thing that's a little
weird about this is that the bottom
level here right this is more like this
structure here just entity goes to
property goes to value it's not been
decorated like this one would expect
instead that this would look like entity
goes to properties goes to blah blah
blah do you see what I'm saying is Tony
here yes I'm here so you understand the
point I'm making
yes well maybe it's redundant we don't
know it depends if there are metal
properties of a single entity which are
not Isis your claim is that there can be
no method meta property of an entity
that all properties of an entity must be
given as properties in that Association
is that correct no there can be computed
properties that apply to everybody yes
where does a computer property go under
proper keys they are pro tight or not
per entity that's them yeah okay that's
a computer property but what I'm saying
is that for a given entity look there's
an asymmetry here right because here
you're saying given a type here's its
list of entities and so on right
yeah then and that's why I wanted to put
that stuff like basically the equivalent
ii gray cell in your notebook i wanted
to put that in the second argument
because that would no no no let's go
back to what i'm saying okay so in this
case you've minimized this so there is
no possibility here of having these for
example computer properties here right
mmm-hmm you've removed the possibility
of that now that's what he's evaluates
to actually so if you don't add implicit
property just a second just saying this
thing here right has more richness than
this here this oh yeah of course of
course I know computer properties this
doesn't have any I cannot have something
that says label that's right that's
right so the point that I'm making is in
here you are not giving as much metadata
opportunity as you could write because
you've got a types level and entities
level both of which can have metadata do
you see what I'm saying whereas at the
bottom level you're copying this and you
cannot have metadata yeah but in a sense
the methods out of a single entity is
the data well that's not totally obvious
to me that's a question for Michael and
Tony
yes one can see it like dead
like what that that it is merely given
in the list of properties or the better
good yes so a list of properties is
generally enough to be used for anything
however you want to classify that data
well the only thing that I could imagine
is that there are things to do with the
maintenance of the entity store that are
needed there that are not supposed to be
exposed like for instance okay
let's imagine that some of these
properties let's imagine there was some
permission structure associated with
these properties you could not represent
that here
well you could represent it that within
the properties key but you cannot make
it per entity so you can't have like so
it's to to put that a different way
you couldn't I mean if you wanted
permissions for entities that will be
hard to adhere those are what's still be
possible we just reserve certain
property strings or even symbols yeah
but that's that's kind of a hack we
don't want to have to do that we want to
be able to say because the whole point
is we've got enough structure here that
we don't have to do that right at the
point that I'm making is I think there
is the that there should be some
mechanism to have
you know what this is is basically
entity property lists this isn't really
a list of entities this is really an
entity property list
or entity values or something that's
what yeah Leah right yeah that is not
really and desire into values right and
we could have a separate list of
entities that could contain metadata
associated with the entities yeah that
is true and that would be actually very
desirable for us working with the SQL
stuff because if you yeah right because
that'll clean then clean he doesn't just
say that entity values has to be empty
if it's you know if it has back-end
whatever it is file SQL RDF then anyway
that's a suggestion Michael and Tony
what do you think about that suggestion
I don't see it why we need different
types of properties is it because we we
should avoid reserved property yes yes
yes most definitely I mean look we said
entities here then we could give all
kinds of metadata associated with those
entities right and if this here was
called entity values
you
then that's what it actually is and
Steven so that means something like a
label should be the metadata of the
entity or should it be a property
it depends what it is listen look I'm
saying we don't yet have any interesting
metadata associated identities but take
my example of permissions okay
of somehow and I don't know exactly how
we're doing it that you are um you know
certain entities can only be accessed by
certain users let's say right that will
be stored there you don't want to store
that in the entity values list
am I making sense I'm not convinced it
is still a property of this entity the
property of the entity is that not
everybody has permission yeah I know but
you but it seems to me more like there
is a set of quantities you don't want
everybody to see maybe okay listen I'm
only making the point okay that we let's
move on but I I'm making the point which
I am probably going to come back to but
I don't think this is properly
symmetrical that is this thing here is a
fully decorated form if you think about
it you could have something like you
know there's no reason why you're
storing the that Association in the
entities you could store it in the
properties transposed yes all right and
I mean you could choose both because
that's quite symmetrical and that's why
I mean since in many backhands that core
part of the data is the part that you
cannot it's it's sorry it's the only
part that you can store on the back hand
that's why I wanted to completely
separate it and put it where we now
we'll put that a basis field object okay
well fine all right so anyway this is a
small point but maybe an important point
let's keep going okay so this is the the
the simplified version of that which is
just type entity property right what
happens if the properties of attributes
I mean this is a very simple example so
they don't know no no I understand but
what does it look like what does the
structure look like when they have a
turn at it we have to look differently
there are various ways of making it you
can you can use the support tables or
you can but if you want this kind of
three level of associations you can't
well I understand some but we have
plenty I mean we care about that
conceptually qualified properties are
just different properties with qualified
I mean attributes like you mentioned low
end rates yes you instead of population
they it goes to 2010
you could have copulation at 2010 one
property so in some sense qualified
properties are just a way of factoring a
large collection of properties so
conceptually there's no problem here
yeah mess right that's also a choice
because for example you could decide to
have the identities and the properties
be so you have like yeah I understand I
understand but still that's kind of a
mess okay let's keep going this this is
I get the basic structure here okay so
so now what are we summarizing here
we're summarizing the access or
mechanisms for these different kinds of
things is that right yes okay so this is
the fully decorated form is entity value
of an entity of a certain type with an
entity property of that type and a
property associated with that type yep
this is the simplified form is to take
your Association and simply look at part
extraction type entity property
okay
fair enough now in the case where the
thing is application well we could do it
as I need polish later three lines down
I need oh and I can do all with
fictional creation right but it were the
thing to be in a data set you could do
it that way mm-hmm okay
it would be more symmetric
right okay but that's
purposes here okay let's keep going so a
single row is entity value entity
property class what the heck is that
it's like saying all the properties
because its own piece identity property
class with no condition ok so that's a
kind of a clunky way to have to ask for
this but I get this way but you can only
meet the second argument can just say
property Association if you don't want I
just wanted to make it out but that's
also kind of I I think that we should
simplify what you know we should provide
some syntax for that you know get all
the properties of that entity
I find that quite useful all the time to
say comma data certain things and it's
kind of clunky right now why all cannot
work cameras are in backwards
can you use all to trigger why not I
mean let's okay so this would be there
um by the way let me save this it would
be by the way you need to bother with
all the code cells before this works
there always it's not registered yeah I
understand I wasn't I was thinking it
wasn't gonna work but but will it work
okay can somebody remind me this is
under databases is that correct is that
storing it yeah it is and yeah in all of
this one not everything works it's not
database backed so yeah okay I
understand okay so I might as well just
run these
no not everything worse than the first
few okay all right okay single column
okay so this is an entity class so
otherwise this could be written you you
don't have to explicitly put that entity
class piece there right
you could just say entity value of the
type or is that not correct
yeah in some places just the type
straightness an alias for all the
entities okay okay enter the Association
right that's of the form entity goes to
value whatever for a given for a given
property I get it okay full table entity
goes to property value right so that's
just the inside that's just the you know
the type indexed piece of that three
level Association I get it okay answered
a list of entity class type okay so
that's otherwise known that's equivalent
if I'm not mistaken to enter the list of
type one correct yes
so
you
whatever
that would normally work if everything
was correctly registered that would work
yes okay
okay
and to the list entity properties
two entities and that's the entity
properties of that entity class okay now
this is something a little bit more
funky here but is what is this exactly
why is there allowed allowed heads
because transpose doesn't allow you to
transpose associations or associations
by default we're working on it it's it's
nailed it okay what we're working on
with Association transpose right that
was the as a function Association
transpose okay um
these can point to entities and other
types what does that mean it means that
like whenever you have like a person who
has multiple books properties
yup that's yes okay but that interaction
happens automatically or that
interaction yeah it no it doesn't happen
in automatically you have to still give
that label of the of the path yes we're
gonna make it work kind of automatically
with the external databases I don't know
how it works with built-in entity stores
like of course you need to do decision I
mean if you have a foreign key to
another table so you have booked and
then an out on then you can you know we
can return the entity out door and this
is just basically symbolizing the record
by American Lawyer to expand the the the
give back on the Association we need to
have a way to do that yeah okay hold on
Tony has the stuff for the whole sparkle
path mechanism of so on of interacting
through multiple kinds of these
relations isn't that correct yes how
does that relate to all of this so so
currently we have to make this
connection yet because we just didn't
get to it but there's also a conceptual
thing that we have to explore because in
the entity worlds we usually have um
operators that we compose via in sparkle
we have more like a variable-length
pattern and there's no real equivalent
of variable length composition no I
understand we've been through this
before right of the question of making a
pattern construct that represents just
like blank blank represents an arbitrary
number of arguments we need some
represents an auditory depth composition
yes and we and we had worked on that
before it hadn't we
we had some contracts for that we had
the idea of property past where you have
a fixed sequence of properties but it
was not arbitrary links well there is
another way to express this stuff which
is a lot more clunky and then been
sparkled that's the old way of SQL
databases and it's called transitive
closure and it uses a basically it's
like recursive with in in this but it's
it's it's really hard to reason around
but seems horrifying yes I mean I don't
think we need to do that but but just
just for a second here what we want to
do is we want to be able to say you know
given something like this right we want
to be able to say an arbitrary depth
nesting of these things right we wants a
pattern yes but why why don't she is why
don't you allow blanks in and key
property paths directly
that no both of you I guess I can sell
something there's a composition which is
which is a little bit more brittle than
actually explicit expected entity
probably path because you're kind of
assuming that things never return I see
but I mean it's still of interest to try
and get from a language structure point
of view it's still of interest to get a
pattern for this
yes yeah and I don't see any fundamental
problem with with you know calling it a
you know composition pattern or
something and essentially what that
would be
yeah I mean I think what were wants to
do is is to make it as if lists so to
speak so it's a composition pattern that
would be something like blank blank and
a composition pattern would mean that
would mean that in other words the the
the rule would be um what is the
function that does that we want to
function what what function takes FGX
like that and turns it into I'm I'm
spacing for a second I mean it's
essentially a fold yes it would not be
too suitable for application to an
argument that is rather find whether
there is such a composition
I understand I understand the thing that
I'm asking the question what function
takes this to that
did you understand my question yeah
we're just it's one that we just added
its pro league I mean the fields of
curry shouldn't do this
no construct does does no construct boy
we should be able to know this
immediately constructive f of X what
does that yes do if you want to usually
fall that will be fold of compose with
compose for I understand it rotated yes
but this is more like
boy I cannot believe we don't ok
represents a composition like that right
boy it's weird that we don't have what's
in it does that what I mean BH is
different from the completion for her
you write what I mean were we to have
such a function this is the pattern
version of that so in other words my
suggestion would be that the pattern
representing F of G of H of X right
would be that we could say if we want it
to composition pattern but then it's not
a composition like it's a composed
pattern is huge at the end you mean it
doesn't have the X that the composition
pattern would be something which in a
literal form might be like that right so
it's similar to just having so one
question is why is it not composition
why is the whole thing not composition
of double blank like that because
composition I mean if you write
compositional blank from a blank that
evaluates whereas blank can't tell but I
see I see I see I see okay but so
composition pattern if we had a
compositional back to the exits I mean
the fact that compositional blank or
blank evaluates it's not a problem
because that would work yes
because it isn't arbitrary length right
yes so this becomes that which is kind
of bizarre but it's still correct right
so so maybe we already have the solution
to this problem maybe it's just putting
patterns into composition but this is I
feel I get too simplistic one because
for practically cases not all of the
functions are univariate
I see okay look this is a separate
discussion let's um where should I save
this also also if you put blend blank
and that evaluates then it actually
means something like you can you can
have at least weird within multiple F's
applied tracks Network match alright
listen this is a separate discussion
let's not let's not go down this um can
we get this into an ILD discussion
please is okay um okay we had a question
on the live stream here to understand
the focus here as on relational database
relationships but in the future will it
be possible to reify relationships in
this model note there's more typical of
entity relationship models and currently
in use by neo4j who can comment on that
to understand what means first Michael
you you you have worked with neo4j is
that not correct but only as a use on
nothing at this level okay
you
I think that the reification is what one
of the things that Tony has in RDF is
like saying so let's say I have an
entity Carlo and an empty Steven and I
want to know what the relationship
within us is it is like
employer-employee so so you instead of
finding the value you're finding the
relationship connecting them what the
property is some RDF there's a concept
reification and it has a well-defined
meaning so it is making statements about
statements I see I see I see I see so
it's taking the edges of the graph so to
speak yes right as well as the nose but
without leaving the graph so there's a
special vocabulary for modeling debt
right I understand alright tip that
that's for the that's we think about
that a little bit okay
okay all right let's keep going here so
entity structure or type like primitives
so those that correspond to a horde
table okay so this is now okay so this
is the functions we were starting to go
over last time right yes okay so this is
the one that I think should be called
entity selection not entity select
doesn't evaluate right yes
okay but so you're saying this
is select on the things of that type
okay so entity selection I think of type
entity function entity function requires
this this that that property be equal to
this now in a more shorthand version of
this we will be saying entity type one
arrow
no type 1 comma property 1 the shorthand
of this is property one arrow val 1 1 is
that not correct and now with every
class
not with ends ok
I find this really confusing this entity
class that's why it's right this is
about you know actually it's it's
conceptually simpler because whatever
has the entity class head corresponds to
a list and every single test the entity
head corresponds to a single see um by
the way somebody is suggesting here that
we use our new chat feature
it's some which we should do so people I
think sander on the livestream was
trying to send a piece of code that got
garbled by some combination of live
streaming software um yes I think that's
not for today because we're gonna mess
around for too long trying to figure out
how to how to set this up correctly but
for another time we should actually use
Wolfram chat and let people send stuff
in through the through our proper chat
channel um that's something for the
folks who are dealing with a live stream
okay
to be continued to continue here okay so
let's let's keep going um
sorry you were explaining entity class
is better than entity because what so
the analogy is that whatever has had
entity class represents a list of
entities well if the head is entity it's
a single single fair enough I just don't
really like the word class because it
reminds me of so many different weird
things you know and originally that came
about because we had named entity
classes like you know European countries
as opposed to something else rather than
this kind of constructed class if you
understand one yeah but but implicit
classes I mean I'll cover it at the end
of this notebook the busy classes can
now be subsumed in engine select and in
some cases in sort by plastic okay I
think that's it right work because it
even so comes it goes around any issue
if it's a set or something like that its
general enough to cover everything
alright fair enough
okay all right entities sort by so that
is sorting this the the entities in that
type by that property okay but again
this is a noun form right because it
doesn't actually do it
this is I mean this is more like if I'm
not mistaken entity sorted by except
unfortunately it's not really entity its
entity it's some kind of yeah it's a
getting classical entity
I mean arguably I mean I hate to say it
but this really is if I'm not mistaken
entity class selection that right or is
that wrong
no it's reflection of the end he is not
of the NC classes no I understand that
but why it's actually select entity
something like this what this is look
this is what this is is entity class
sorted by a micro but there is shortened
is an objective 22 class and then in the
other case selection it's not an
objective 22 class why not because it's
going to give an entity class oh it's
entity class selected or entity class
filtered not flexion no I understand not
a selection of the entity class it is
selected to give an entity class we are
is a thing selected to give an entity
class so maybe it is correctly entered a
selection okay let's keep going here
well I don't dislike the idea of their
most starting with entity class rather
than with energy I have a little bit of
conceptual problem with this one it is
definitely useful and we wanted but it
is somehow conceptually different in the
sense of it is a useful tools for how to
get certain things out in a certain
order but this say this equality and
also sings I'm concerned we are digging
holes us that we never come out when
what a quality thing like is you start
with a certain entity class and then you
sorted by it equal to or not right right
I mean what do we think is the answer
for that for associate is not okay but
so for associations they are ordered and
they are not equal the association with
he's a and B is not the same as the one
with keys being a correct
yeah I'm correct about that right
for pattern matching it is possible to
pull out an association is considered
all of us for purposes of pattern
matching so in other words if I have a
pattern that says is that is that
correct no only this the key value
pattern you can ignore the order
okay right so if you're pulling out a
particular entry or collection of
entries they can be pulled out
regardless of the order in which they
happen to appear that correct on
interest yes okay
comment about this entity sort it's not
necessarily an entity class that's being
sorted in principle wherever you can
have a class you can have the explicit
list of entities so this represents the
list of entities in the sorted order so
we shouldn't make it too specific to
class
I see except when you have a list they
you already evaluate to sing to separate
entities and the class stays more lazier
than that yeah that would be a problem
if the data changes
that's where it's not really that
equivalent okay let's keep going we're
going to have to loop back to this okay
the very bizarre entity annotation which
I can't stand the name of I mean that's
the thing that basically pops up more it
is a thing that adds more properties to
an entity right and yes you'll be entity
up there if you think in term of a
cessation well I don't think
I can't stand entity append either
that's totally weird I mean this is
basically the description is represents
let's write the description ok
represents a new infant class an entity
class y'okay an entity class in which
properties a computed property basically
in which computer properties have been
added to entities correct I mean the
entities
it is a computed property right it's
always it's it's not a computed property
in the same sense as the entity store
because if we if we're I mean this
against SQL we're guaranteeing you that
this can be run against SQL well the one
Bernard added the NT store or evaluated
your language okay that's it that's an
implementation detail I mean you know in
other words there might be certain
functions that won't work here for the
time being but conceptually this is this
is effectively mapping onto you know
what this is effectively doing is
mapping this function across the
entities and appending that property
right yes function across entities and
appending a property but it should be a
little bit more general than computed
because we use computed in the sense of
that existing properties are enough to
express it but you might have your very
own there you did you want to give it to
something this is this is by tight right
this is not by entity this is this is
only depending on I mean you could have
a table here that says for this
particular entity do this access to the
X do we have a complete at your hand and
then you can decide what you want to
give it
how does computer properties work in an
entity store for a property you specify
the so called default function
for each entity for which there's no
value this default functions okay okay
so that's it so hold on let's let's
capture that that thought here because
that is that's a different thing right
because that could be done here as well
right
Oh any fault property property values as
a matter of fact there there is
something in a scabbard correspond to
our missing hue which is called this now
that does just that so if you you can
put something that says if is now and
there's actually even a more compact
version saying that this code call s
which means basically take the first
value in this list that's not now and
usually you put the actual value in the
table right but so one thing we might
want is to say given
in in this setup right so a thing we
might want to do is quotes annotate and
I can't stand the name um a an entity
class by putting something something
putting by computing a property value
whenever one is whenever there's missing
right now
is that right
I mean that would be a typical thing we
might want to do this is as opposed to
its support but say oh yeah here's a
good example so you might very know the
sum of the mass of two things without
knowing the individual words how do how
do we represent that here but but hold
on but one of the features here is that
in this entity annotate you are
appending that property it is not the
property already exists and you're
modifying it yeah but you can shadow the
older one okay so wait a minute so this
so this function will the
will overwrite an existing value for a
property so let's understand how that
relates to what happens in an
association so if I say in an
association a goes to 1 a goes to 2
right
that will be okay so that does the same
thing so that's the same that's why the
analogy to append is so close because an
entity is in some sense an association
and then you append a property goes to
value it's not quite the right level bow
but yes I can append yes yeah we don't
have a function that is doing that with
the easterlies physician I mean that
sounds useful like you have a list of
keys and function for every key and you
get back a new list of association with
you know the new key that is computed by
a function well walk me through that
again so you have a list of associations
yes and then you provide basically
another association with key goes to
function
I see I see yeah so by the way there is
a in the chat mini carps proposes entity
bind should yes and a few others but NC
bind I like I don't I I don't understand
it well I mean with the word I
understand why we might say that I'm not
convinced an idea the word bind is an
interesting one that hasn't been used
elsewhere but let's but you can think of
binding as a mapping of of appending
it's like you bind to a whole side over
things that are just appending tour to a
row okay hold on let's let's let's loop
back for a second to what Ricardo is
saying here okay so let's understand
this function that you're proposing
so you're saying given a list of
associations you're saying what what are
you suggesting you're suggesting then
you have another associational functions
yeah right just mouth
so how does this relate to association
map so association map will take a
function and map
and create an association by mapping
over keys right
so this is so so wait a minute
association map creates an association
by mapping over keys
you
okay now what you're proposing is
something which maps over
Maps over a list of associations
and then what's it gonna do and then for
each so the new function maps over lists
of associations actually if you can work
out some monetization so you have an
association and ionisation of function
and then basically the result will be oh
I see it's actually you know it's
association through yeah it works like -
okay so let's understand what it is so
for a given key right it's it's gonna
have an association of keys so it's
gonna say key one is f1 key - is f2
right and then it's going to take let's
take the one association case it
actually doesn't matter what you take on
the right we take anything we have been
at one applies to the right well done so
that this so in this case but it doesn't
do that the team that we are doing with
entities basically you have an
association and then you have another a
cessation of function in then you you
resolve each function but then you also
measure you don't have data it's when
you do one movie you have one function
at the time even well but you have a you
see that you have a rule goes to
function
now you're gonna keep this is this is
the behavior to correct that you're
taking the the what this is saying is
given the associations are going to have
this is a an association of functions
that are being provided to apply
themselves to the corresponding keys in
here but that's that's not that's not
true through is anything on the right
this is more like thread yes I agree but
we already have a concept of Association
thread what is that it doesn't do that
so association thread
I see I see that creates an association
from this is more like
and apply right
or a map thread
what is this is the
Association map thread what would
Association map thread look like no
that's not the right thing either no
it's it is actually thread inna
I mean Association thread is Association
and not first rather than Association
like you're right a direct creation of
compositional trend this is really doing
the same thing that's correct
i I don't know what this could be thread
could just be thread like a threat
it should work this way no no because
this is function application right
that's not what thread does threaten or
combine those things no right it's
through with it doesn't
I think so I mean through but but this
this concept is given a collection this
is a some kind of key apply
I think
or something more like
so it's a very it's a funky thing I mean
it's something more like Association
apply because what you're doing if you
take you have teeth drop we're gonna
have key yeah either key apply order or
key this is not doing anything to the
keys it's leaving the keys unchanged so
it's not a key in living yes right but
it's actually more like negotiation
about using the function what heats
creating a new key by using a function
look this thing it doesn't have to be
about associations and I am now
convinced that we don't have an
equivalent concept it is a through
thread
it's like takes two lists and then
applies the first function to the first
element
i suture saying okay so let's look at
that concept okay so you're saying
through thread and it will be just F 1 F
2 F 3 and then a list ABC and the result
of that would be F 1 of a F 2 of B etc
yeah and then by the fundamental demo of
Association then you know why it has to
do with associations
why is that through thread why is that
what what does that have to do with
through and through is one of our
failure functions as far as I'm
concerned it's been there since version
1 and few people including me who
invented it have ever understood it
let's remind ourselves what it actually
does oh my gosh if you put the list at
one out of two or three and then just X
on the right yeah but let's let's take
this case okay so thread through does
that rather bizarre thing I think I
really dislike about true is that it
doesn't take two arguments but actually
that's the failure to me thank God
because this way has to hold it's weird
yes I mean look the idea of it
originally was
yeah I mean it had it had an idea
originally 30 years ago 32 years ago by
now probably um okay but let's go back
here I think this is an interesting
construct also be called apply threat
difference to argument but that is not
really what we are doing we don t do it
right because we don t learn today you
have an existing association of variable
length like we date keys and then you
are adding two or three keys by using a
function yeah I agree I agree so it's
not really you're gonna that's not yes
its merging the result with with
existing data supply threat of threat
apply apply thread is an interesting
name for this construct I agree by the
way if you're interested in what's the
closest equivalent if you expand the
code thing in entity yeah bare below but
you'll see that it's actually just map
of a pen yes with functional creation
but hey yeah I understand I understand
it's map append except that it that
that's the case where that key does not
already exist
all right no I see what you're saying
but there isn't tonight so we're writing
it what one point here is that this the
function here is taking the entity as an
argument right not for example an
existing value I mean you might imagine
that this funky I think Association it's
not pretty it's applying to the let's
just try and keep ourselves organized
here for a second so this is the
possibility of a an apply thread
function which we should discuss as an
ILD function subsequently and this now
is we're talking about this here is your
entity annotate whose name I can't stand
um but
what I'm saying is this in here
um
this thing this X here what is this
taking I mean I would one of the things
that the function could take um is the
existing value of that property because
this maybe that could be nobody does it
does you how but they're still limited
Stern understand okay I'm sorry so the
function the function simply the
function takes an entity the function
that is provided so what you're doing is
give let's say yeah that's actually
entity value nope not functional
application or extra property one no I
understand it but given an entity you
are applying a function
a potentially new property right yes yes
and by the way the idea of saying that
you want to only add it if it's missing
we would call that entity impute 8m
puked you mean yeah he impute yeah sorry
it's actually we're using um I mean
actually what we would that would be
rather entity missing impute a impute
because the function that we have in
machine learning which is not in eleven
three is it missing imputation no it
didn't make it
no it's not the UM the
okay that's the let's not go down that
particular rathole because that that
that leads to all kinds of funky stuff
about well anyway that's always
something that you can write with entity
on my paper okay let's let me still
understand what the core concept of what
you're calling entity annotate is it is
taking a given implicitly represented
class of entities but can this be an
entity class or can it only be a type
all of these things compose okay so I
could slay and to the annotate of entity
selection event right okay so what this
is saying is this is a way of appending
properties
okay so this thing is whatever I just
brought it's actually very interesting
so if you if you were in the other way
around entry selection or entity on a
date you can create a probability and
then use it in a subsequent filter and
this is actually 1.2 SQL what you're
doing is basically a width but is on the
other direction yes but this is a way of
it the fundamental thing here is this
what this is achieving and I understand
your append concept here um I mean what
would happen if we called this
oh gosh I don't know this is a horrible
name that's horrible
that's me yeah it's her I mean but in
addition this is not a thing that
evaluates correct yes
nothing evaluates until you say aunt
idealist or whatever hmm or entity value
if so
or entity properties in a way that's
horrible to
um no I mean I say entity properties
does evaluate no I understand I
understand I'm this named entity
appended is equally horrible ah so the
issue is
I think we need yeah I mean entity
property odd not a pen oh just up enter
the property add that sounds like an
l-value
I mean that sounds like a thing that
makes mutable changes so to speak mutate
something which is not right yeah that
is also that I don't like I don't like
it to start with entity property because
it's not an entity property like thing
it's an in class like thing
right but it is not showing it is acting
on properties and yes it from that
moment on you get a new profit know
exactly not yet on the whole entity
class what about auntie class extension
it's interesting
I mean the problem with these things the
problem with that name is it sounds
you're adding entities not properties
yes that also has a different meaning in
the sparker context what would it be
then precisely defining the semantics
they talk about the entity class
extension which is the set of all
entities in that class so they're making
this distinction between class and the
entities that are in that class what
about something like this
under the proper extension but but is
true that if you think in terms of
inheritance then you are basically
taking you know a set of property and
you're adding and you're basically
creating a new class that got the whole
property plus those two yeah well anyway
I think naming game is fun but that was
not the original objective at this
meeting and we don't have a lot of yeah
I understand
fun is not what I would characterize
naming us okay the naming is very hard
work
well yeah it's fair but we need to think
from this okay all right fine fine all
right so I would say that the least
crazy names here have the word extension
in them
yeah I agree um yeah it's actually clear
what it is but you're creating a new
runtime poverty type yes so I was gonna
originally call this group by and today
aggregate fine but well that's the next
function we're lucky yes yeah okay all
right I think I've understood this
function finally now you're gonna throw
another function okay so this is works
kind of like goodbye in the Wolfram
language but it has different ordering
of arguments and like if there are some
things that are compulsory that are not
in indeed by so basically what this does
is that it takes an existence class you
are setting it collapses it by prop one
yes and then it takes the groups each
group and applies entity function to it
so in this case it takes and like the
entity function takes entity classes not
single entities
laughs that's why Knights of the neck
total entity function is not allowed to
do that enter the function is a creature
that takes entities isn't it now it's a
creature that takes I mean actually
function as the same semantics says
identity value
so easily if you look at the way at
x-bar property but let me let me
understand that claim okay your claim is
entity function so entity value can take
so this is entity value versus entity
function semantics it's actually entity
property and the function have the same
semantics well no wait a minute
what's he talking about because entity
value right can take you're saying
entity value let's imagine entity value
takes in let's give it an entity class
okay okay what I'm thinking that if you
see any value of NC class comma entity
function or call my entry God but am I
gonna get here let's say I say a class
of countries here for Europe right now
that's entity value now I say GDP for
example here mm-hmm
so now I'm going to get something which
implicitly does no okay so that that
gives me a list right
yes but I believe what you can do is now
in severe identity property very sir of
GDP yeah right ante property country
comedy deeply
okay now wait were they empty list
as the third argument and then total as
the fourth here yep it's undocumented
but just to show you that it's the same
semantics okay um you know you see what
I'm saying
is that an entity property the entity
property takes the whole class then it
kind of lists on it unless it has I
unless you do something else at the end
of it like the fact that it returns a
list of the same length or they write
but that's doing entity function like
stuff with that bizarre 4th ultimate for
entity property yes but what I'm saying
is that the entity function semantics is
the same at the end it's not the right
analogy because this is not considered
an entity property what not this
aggregating property there's completely
different properties in the sense of how
it behaves from all other properties
okay
okay what I'm saying is that in terms of
application behaves the same okay let's
go back to entity function for a second
okay my understanding of entity function
is that it is an unavailing thing that
takes
as an argument so just write any
function of x over square bracket
population well okay yeah right okay so
this thing here could you claim that's
equivalent to
that thing is equivalent to entity
property
of now it has to have a type right
yes of GDP
now why does entity function not have
the other type because it's applying
itself to the society type the
properties that you call can have a kite
so there you can actually expand that
more and say that instead of every X
apply to GDP in there and that's an
explicit entity value and to the
property creature yes but that's just
the shorthand and we actually do support
and see value in there okay so what's
the difference so why do we need the
function entity function because I think
that it's important well first of all we
need to distinguish from what function
does with Association which has very
specific semantics secondly I think it's
also important that we are explicit in
the fact that this doesn't run in the
kernel but it's gonna be very important
for people who are doing performance
critical things so if this is going to
run over 1 million 1 billion rows you
better make sure that that's something
that is externally evaluated and not and
so I can be done out of cor well k bit
so so your claim is that the entity
family of functions are all non
evaluating creatures except except when
evaluating the essential properties
right it's a little weird that this
thing that the feature that is different
here I mean that would otherwise just be
X of GDP it's equivalent its value is
the same as X of GDP it's merely that it
does not run immediately right
yeah yeah just like function but the
difference with functions that in
function you have this thing rigged
insane you know in functioning to put
everything and it's actually completely
opaque watch good and you can replace it
with a symbol with down values and the
function no it has to be there has to be
explicit and it has very specific
semantics about what can be put yeah I
understand I you know maybe it's name is
not totally totally obviously correct
it's really a function because you can
apply it to a single entity and it will
do it probably an ant heap property
function but it's more likely problem
like knowledge but you're saying enter
the property function I don't quite
understand that I mean so why are you
calling it that I mean it's it is a
function that applies itself to entities
and classes of entities correct and such
it isn't a property like so if these are
prized then I see what you're saying
properties are kids
I see what you're saying so in other
words this is that's actually an
interesting name and city property
function because entity property is the
immediate evaluation thing so if I say
entity property of you know country you
know GDP whatever population whatever it
is right and then I say here USA um then
that is the immediate well okay so there
are two forms of this that I can do I
can either do that or I can treat that
as a function and I can apply it to this
correct
but you will be able to do the same with
any function no and hold on so the
function hold on
enter the property function if I were to
write that here would not evaluate until
I said no it would it would no you just
told me it wouldn't allow you it until I
send to the value no no no this syntax
is like and D value is like a shorthand
for any value and so if empty properties
and that's the problem function isn't a
property like then it implies that this
gets expanded in 20 body blah okay so
then what is the case where this doesn't
evaluate I mean you know also I point
out entity property doesn't evaluate
either yeah yeah it's the same as into
the property exactly
okay so then here then this form is
entity property function
and then your point here is that this
could say you know that the point is to
make a nice notation where this can say
X overpopulation and so on right so you
can do a computation like that which is
a just do this computation start with
properties unless you wants this algebra
of keys and this allows you to do this
in a clean way right so I think you're
right that this is really enter the
property function rather than entity
function
I'm not certain but this is look looking
at these two cases so that the direct
analog of this
let's keep going here for practical
cases I would it would be there would be
a different version for this for a 1546
so the entity function automatically
lists efficiently so it behaves like an
entity property that can be applied to a
list of entities but we wouldn't give
her own attribute like we can have it's
not necessary Michael because it already
internally does that anyway
it's not immediately applied in the
query all right it was the least it will
know that it deals with the least or
with the collection I agree okay let's
look some more here actually let's just
look at a couple of things from the live
stream here Michael Hale is asking is
the allowed heads option for transpose
going to be documented I believe the
answer is no because we are trying to
make a proper Association transpose oh
gosh it's mentioned deep in one tutorial
that's kind of horrifying um
yeah I believe that where we're going
with that is we're intending to have an
association transpose is that correct
or is this the wrong group to ask that
question Sushma do you know
oh it's it's not you in Alec you okay
but I can push that forward
um okay Michael Hill apparently I've
used through before in the situation
okay this is a discussion of through
okay let's let's move on here um so okay
agregate without by yes we means
collapse everything into one so it's
it's it's really like entity are great
by with the empty list as the second
argument however wait wait wait so we
start and gotten through this Ellen
together so what aggregate does is like
your list of countries you aggregate by
continent and then you add some computed
properties that are like the mean and
the total I don't know the population
alright but so what you're doing then is
you're okay so you've got the two steps
you're aggregating
by a property as in grouped by correct
yes it can be a several properties at
the same time stone so can group by
right yes then having aggregated by a
property then apply a function to the
elements of the aggregate to the to the
complete aggregated lists that correct
as in
um okay so why is this a single function
because you will do it in one step
basically why because you can't if you
aggregate and then you don't you don't
do anything then you only get the thing
you aggregate it on you don't get
anything else because most database
backhands don't have a way to represent
arrays of things and so everything if
you don't so this is not a notation feed
you know it's not in potential future
because you always do it in one step you
don't update and then do a bunch of
other things and then remember that you
had aggregated before you aggregate and
you wanna get something else right but
what you're saying is for those okay so
what you're doing here is you're saying
aggregate on that property
I I'm actually for butyl auntie's you
need this why do you need that I don't
understand that given that property what
you're saying is what I'm saying is that
for for building entities you can even
return these or a built-in mmm
aggregators like we do have for things
like when you when you know I understand
okay so the general form is a class
representation which could be just a
type name yeah the thing to aggregate
over the the let's say it's prop AG prop
I guess could be one or more properties
it could be an entity function could be
where your one or more edged functions
how can it be an entity function can be
an l2 function just lose the ability to
refer to that thing again
but it's let me just understand honking
property function right so what this
does is it produces things which it
produces an association which has been
in which the outer layer let's just
imagine it's a single property here mmm
then the outer layer of the values of
that property look at the one example
above that it I can see property one
goes to one one one
okay lovely okay but now
I don't understand this I don't
understand this is this is doing some
kind of entity extension thing on top of
this we really could be doing it has to
now wait a second why isn't it just
applying a function to the whole thing
that could be a function that is entity
extension or could be another function
right it could be a function that for
example replaces this list by the total
of all properties or something
because those functions like entity
extensions are are all morphisms in the
class and in this case we want something
that goes from a class to a single and
that's why
wait why is this going to a single
entity well because it so okay so you
think you think think let's go back up
the countries you take a single
continent but what you want out is a
list of Europe Asia Africa etc you don't
want you don't want to still see Italy
in Europe it's been flattened out and
this is similar to what we already do
with food entities for example it's it's
very similar to the way in peace
identities work that they are like a
mean or a total entity okay I understand
that but the the semantics of this thing
so there's a function here right and
that function of what this is saying is
take this class create aggregations
according to that property and to those
aggregations apply this function yeah
but that function has to return exactly
one entity
it's not an entity yes if it gets
applied to each subclass and then
returns an entity and the new class is
made up that single and it actually
returns the property but you can apply
several no no but what few many things
that if that were a function instead of
a list of rules that function has to
return an T that's why it's the Brutes
as the second order why does it have to
return that we are not seeing okay what
I'm saying is that you are in countries
young aggregates on continents what you
want out has to be like a new entity
type which is continent so you just have
five four seven however recount and
seizing it each one of them will have a
bunch of properties so that is a
function that takes a class every
tournament if you want to consider it
that way and we don't have such a
constructor so hold on listen just as a
practical structuring of this mating we
clearly have more to talk about here but
I want to just get through the scope of
everything okay
okay so you've got
a variety of other functions that take
that take entity classes
various kinds and return
and the glasses are these all entity
class two entity class is that signature
that's what I'm doing
yes that's what I was listing there okay
so this is entity class two entity class
the only one that's a bit special is its
Joanna cross that is from two and three
classes - what you going to class yeah
which is some kind of threading
operation isn't it yeah it can
yeah it can't read but there is also
entity unloading thread that we plan to
interest but I didn't put here because
once you get into the annotate then we
can talk about a generator and today as
extension thread goes okay let's we've
got more to figure out here but you had
another hole what is this what is this
is basically why you are working there's
actually a third one that's the one you
were looking at today below so once you
have the operate on one of these classes
the question is what are the entity
properties that it exposes and so
basically there is a sort select and and
class that don't change the properties
annotate or actually extension adds the
property aggregates remove some
properties and had some new ones and so
this is the way this is the algebra on
the property sides can we write that out
in a more explicit I mean a more in a
cleaner form limbless what but if you if
you claim that this is a I mean it's
something like a type algebra
yes yes yes um okay we should play right
out that algebra and make sure we have
the difference yeah yeah I mean I have
it I have it seen called x-ray or just
read something cool okay find that yeah
let's take let's take a recreational
break and let's see Ricardo's demo
okay sure okay go ahead share please
okay so okay so basically let's say that
you have an external database this is
the negation of my database
you just run database inspect and this
guy is returning an object without the
information about the the underlying
database well the inspector wasn't the
cool database to connect it's not it's
not I mean it's actually doing an
operation of inspecting the database so
it's connecting to the database and then
it is executing some query in order to
see what's inside when you connect it's
returning a database object that happens
to have in it information about what's
in the database yes but it's very
separate function database Connect
I thought we had such a function we have
such a function where this function just
connect to the database it doesn't need
to waste time inspecting the schema if
you're ready at the schema so this is
actually an aberration that you do and
you know you you were following this
operation now you are a representation
of the schema in you're not look at that
and then basically you just for now you
just call entity store around the schema
and you register them and anyone using
register entity store I can do that as
well doesn't matter doesn't matter but
but but I want to come back to this
database inspect thing why is I mean
database Connect will also return an SQL
database object is that not true okay
this is based on internal connections
and and so they went when so when you a
schema might or might not return
contains all the information about the
database so you can inspect and select
only two tables for example if you have
like a huge database with hundreds of
table and you know that not only you
will be only dealing with two of them
your own database inspect with just
those two tables and you get back
basically the schema for those two I
don't think those inspectors write the
right word I mean what this is doing is
it's and by the way database object
suggests it's an object that represents
the whole database what you're saying
it's it is it's a particular wot of the
database yes it might be a subset in
mine it's what would be the name that
you would give to such now but it's a
database and then it contains tables
it's the whole database it's all
database but see Ron is saying that it's
not the food database because it might
contain sort of stuff that are not there
and that that is correct I mean in in
code you're gonna have a representation
of a database that you know at that
moment roughly this is some kind of
database view is that not true the thing
that you're returning or no no we can't
use no it's so someone from the live
stream says why not just apply a meta
but that may be in response to something
it's there in response to something
we're talking about now I'm not sure um
if somebody understands that no okay all
right let's move on um okay so first
thing I'm flagging here is I don't think
these names are quite right but but
that's very beautiful you can get to
from that database you can now okay so
now yes okay so basically what is the I
did automatically is that you know there
are several tables and one happens to be
named title and so basically now you can
directly refer if that entity store
called with the with the SQL database
object evaluates to a form where there's
a first argument that's a lot like the
one
the Tony has but contains no data so
that means that you'd do get
automatically constructed metadata about
this stuff and that you would then
annotate it what the heck is that that
thing there what is that well let's hold
them at admit that you need them
don't don't delete that show that again
it's not will say that an entity of type
it will actually this isn't right it's
not a tawny form this is your this is
your is a bizarre skeleton of your
compressed three-level Association no
it's me it's just missing one thing
which is type no II don't think this
Messing type it's missing and today's
it's missing never have entities will
never have entities because the okay
you're right but then properties when
you say properties there and the right
hand side is a null Association I don't
understand what that means
Tony can you comment on that that's the
same finger tell me any hair disease
okay
nobody copied it from from what it was
doing so the point is that it's saying
that there are no properties there are
no metal properties of that property
exactly no okay fine it's a little weird
yeah maybe I could allow like there are
never any metal properties that property
could be instead of a list of its ever
Association of empty associations could
just be a list
okay that's possible but I mean you're
saying there's one level of type
declaration is in there okay fine all
right now enter the list so given this
wait wait
record is jumping okay so given that
entity type title okay you are then
generating an entity list of the things
with that entity type yes so this is our
test database that is called bits and it
contains several tables and title is is
the title of a book actually though
maybe it would be nice if it remembers
the incantation that showed the graph of
the schema sure it should be a matter of
this guy I cannot remember it all right
it's called it's some database utilities
if you can call those then it's called
the base table growth plot these are the
the graph plot like that yes but you
need to load database utilities for that
databases utilities strange database
table graph plot why don't you look it
up later no okay you go on so far I'll
just interrupt yeah okay
all right keep going here and so yes and
so basically if you ask for the end of
the list
you got basically turned right yes okay
then if we we can extract some
properties and ask for properties
physician why don't you just our dataset
she can do that try it and lose the data
set at the beginning
oops yes okay beautiful okay so hold on
hold on this okay so the first element
there in that entity value is the title
is the title entity right okay I get it
yep
beautiful yes so now let's see how and
fortunately what service I need to fool
if I qualify disabled this is not in
system contracts yet so and so basically
you can call entity volume directly with
anything function and so that's using
the duality with entity property there
because naively I could also do if you
say entity class title and I don't
understand why there's that null list
needed it's the second argument there
but anyway if I just say if you just say
just try the following just try the
following no not that just try it entity
Open bracket
mm-hm making yourself make a new cell
making yourself okay yes so I found the
function if say okay hold on just say
quotes price there okay so that will
give a okay great so that gives a list
of the values of price for each entity
of type title correct yes yes by the way
if you know I wanted to point out
something SQL as different semantics
than the working language here because 2
times missing is missing and I don't
know if this should be considered a bug
in the current entries or a bug in SQL
is they I think it's desirable that
these things propagate is if you do
missing divided maybe see it should not
well I think there are different kinds
of missing sometimes you want this
sometimes you don't yeah but missing
simplifying a fraction not missing
divided by missing that's very bad it's
like no wait waiting waiting right now
if you say missing if not available
divided by missing is not available
you'll get one
yes right what I'm saying is that if
you're doing that with entities and like
your computing some kind of density and
you get into a column where both are now
it should not get one no absolutely I
mean look I've been arguing for some
kind of UUID mechanism for missings for
ages but nobody has been buying that mmm
yeah but I see what you're saying that
you should that only things should be
implicitly unique that's correct no as
in determinants are implicitly unique
yeah indeterminate like two times asking
for the same missing not variable it's
the same missing node variable I know if
they were you you Aidid we'd be in good
shape this depends how you ad like if
every time you make a new one you're bit
in bad shape no I understand but every
entry in the database if every entry in
the database has a UUID
and that UUID is recorded in it's
missing that every time you are yes for
the you know the the density of you know
einsteinium or something as a gas or
some such other thing which probably is
well that would mean that basically i
mean we actually do have something that
says that missing should kind of always
have two arguments and so they're
missing not available could be could
also have information about the entity
in the property yes it could and perhaps
it should it should yeah well better
ewing i think part of the issue with
that is where the missing should have a
print form and we keep on having the
argument with it i about not hiding
what missing is in a print form
and then like yesterday he was trying to
introduce some other weird thing that
hid the structure in a print form so I
don't know what I don't know what you
just Michael I'm curious what your view
is about whether missing should have a a
more you know content hiding print form
I would say yes that's what I think too
well alright so let's that lets a
separate discussion can we please bring
that up
Sushma I think that's for you to bring
up that up I guess a chameleon ILD
mating although alright so let's keep
going to look at the scheme because I'm
also a master it works for me perfectly
okay yeah I can okay so so basically
wait I think I did something okay yes so
so this is how it looks
you have several tables and you can
explai but it was it still has a status
of utility function right now because it
doesn't scale too many more tables so
far but using standard graph yeah it's
using layered graph plot and I just
introduced a custom vertex labeling
function that
represents the tables why the incense
okay so understand those arrows then
arrow means what the area means that a
relation so in this case for example
let's take the title on the publisher
yes yep
so by the way in terms of this
verification thing that was discussed
earlier the dual of this graph is I mean
those relations could be you could you
could make a dual version of this graph
yes
yeah but that would be a hyper graph
yeah why because you can have multiple
like look at title it has four arrows
coming in I okay fair enough okay that's
not so useful
okay well that's cool very nice so the
question of scaling for this is it the
case that if we expect bigger ones of
these that we really need something more
like what system modeler does where you
can click a an area of the graph and her
on yes we open yes yes it is the case
and the other thing we might find useful
here would be to filter out certain you
know certain connections that we are not
interested in so yeah but very something
that we should really do also in code
like like what I'm thinking is that for
example here there is the title so if
you look at title editor editor and
title yeah that that relation you're
actually trying to represent a relation
between the title and the editor it's
only that is the many-to-many relation
and so ask UL implements it with the
support table yes but it's more than
that because it also creates more than
that but suppose you were when you're
constructing the entity store you might
want to attract away title editor and
just make you know do yes that thing
then just make a big edge from editor to
title sure is not a foreign key but it's
managed many these it's actually very
powerful to reason at it but sometimes
the supporting table might contain other
data and then
what I said here because there are four
other other you know other fields but in
many cases what cow is saying is that it
will be only for relating to tables and
then we could use a some different kind
of arrow to represent that that in some
cases instead of what Stephen is saying
that we may zoom in certain part of a
larger structure an alternative would be
that we'll have a way to specify only
the relations we want so that we only
kind of cut out the tables we want and
they will be small and humble then you
know the general thing that we need is a
version of graph in which a super node
in which you can have super nodes that
have some kind of click behavior yeah
but this is not strictly hierarchical
you see it's not hierarchical at all no
no I understand I understand but but you
where you can take a sub graph of this
all yeah yeah and say you know compress
it I mean that's similar to code folding
for a graph so to speak that particular
issue about kind of sub graph what can
we call it sub graph elision or
something that that is a discussion that
we should have because that relates also
to the way that system model of stuff is
put into the language and that probably
is a discussion sushma right maybe you
can get that discussion to happen that
will involve Charles and Roger and some
other people okay
so sub graph illusion for system modeler
and database schemer visualization
okay sorry go ahead so what I was saying
is that imagine you take again you
relation like this that is possibly made
many and you say like it's wedding
between people and then you might have a
table with the weddings that have also
has start date mandate of weddings and
from that you could construct two
different type of relationships which is
like current weddings and
all previous spouses of a person wait by
the way somebody on the livestream is
asking come on annotate this diagram
with one time information like the
dimension to understand the size of
these tables I would imagine the odds
that it's yes right yeah
I mean the thing is that it would you
expect it tells you what the dimension
is and then maybe five minutes later
it's only then obviously the sizes of
the tables are not going to change
yeah but the question was probably about
the visual way to represent that
information for sure we can add that
just asking of the database tell you the
size of the yes right so so what I was
saying is that from one one of these
relations you could also add a filter on
the relation and say you know and
synthesize several properties depending
on the filter so the example was we have
a table that represents weddings you
have abstract away the table and then
each person has a current spouse
property and past spouses property but
it goes through the same table so I
guess what color a correct me if I'm
wrong what you're saying is that in
addition to relations which exist as
auroral relations in the database it
will be much more powerful when we
include relations we can define
ourselves and the users can and they
will also be represented in a certain
very appealing with visual way but what
I mean thing is that another thing is
that so in relational you do several
hops
like several of these raw area oranges
can become relation yeah together but
the other thing you can do is that when
you are on an oath of this graph you can
have a filter
yeah sure so these are you will name you
will name that then differently so you
have you have two weird two wedding
relations and both of them will be based
on the same intermediate table exactly
yes
and we need the primitives graphical
primitives or design how we nicely
represent all that so that someone can
just have a brief look at this schema
which will be much rich or visually and
immediately she was going on yeah but
first we should probably have it working
in pure code anyway so I'll stop sharing
yup okay let's go back to recorder then
okay anti-defection yeah we ready mm-hmm
a bizarre picture of entity value is
that fundamentally enter the value of a
comma B is a of B or in this case a wing
array it's the other way around
anyway Julian a comma b SP a is Eve - or
1025 you what it's a shorthand for
entity value and Philon use the real way
of calling that like entity has a
submenu that called vents value I'm
sorry I'm noticing something on the live
stream that's crazy
somebody saying currently there's no
data import in the Wolfram language go
look at the documentation it's a
function called import that imports 400
different kinds of things um anyway okay
let's keep going so yeah so what I was
saying is that when you come entity with
sub values with you apply a property to
an entity that's that's just calling
entity value and D values the true for
you know it freaks me out somebody
shouldn't have sent this through in the
lifestream it just it freaks me out that
people think that you can't import data
and Wolfram language it like for 30
years you've been able to do that it's
kind of what on earth do we have to do
to get people actually understand what
well maybe they meant something more
specific still on something like
importing from a database as a kind of
direct SQL format is something like that
who knows okay all right to be continued
okay so keep going okay then we have
emptied aggregate by and what this thing
is doing is that the new part oh yeah
right because then I wanted a great
point so this is an aggregate take the
class creates this new property okay
scroll down what are we gonna see here
so we're seeing these various functions
that we were talking about before which
was still designing we're seeing these
actually implemented here right is that
the point yes okay and not only is not
only the implementation of the new
functions it's actually all of them
running against database on the campus
computer so if I took one of those
functions I could see in principle the
SQL translation of what was being asked
here is that right that's another of
lemons tell me one just just so I
understand how horrifying it is give me
a couple of like a minute or two I will
dig up the name for this function okay
because it's in utilities and so this is
actually doing a filter by using the
arrow syntax mm-hmm and this is with
annex about like an A plus identity
filter yes it is not like it is
okay wise women there are two filters
there
what is that syntax okay so this is the
other filter where basically you combine
those filters together right so this is
this is basically an hand which
basically are saying that you want the
entity to have Tyrone business and the
price to be greater than but if you want
to do or or you need to do some complex
stuff where basically you are comparing
two columns together like you're saying
that for example age must be greater
than something or or from another field
from the end in itself in general you
need to use a function and so you can
compare field with each other you can
say you know give me a building where
those two fields get the same value or
anything that you represent basically
with this kind of operators right I
understand the other thing is a
simplified version of what you can do
with an entity function yes yes okay
because basically what we were doing
with entity select okay so to start on
you can basically feed the entities like
directly a function and use it or you
use basically you can create a new
property and then use it later to select
which is why the way you nest the
structure is really important right so
just to understand the shape of what we
have to do the set of functions that
you've been talking about here is more
or less the complete set that you think
we need for this for the subsystem we're
building here is that true so first of
all we haven't really gone into take
because we think the result is very easy
to do in SQL but offset is not that easy
so take from 100 to 200 might be as low
as taking the whole 200 if we don't do
it properly and generate thread that is
related to market relations and will not
get done with the working relations okay
but so just so we're clear
I mean there is more design work to be
done on these functions but we are
definitely getting closer I mean it's
probably another couple of hours of
polishing to get these functions nailed
it will be good to make sure we don't
have a boatload of other functions that
are suddenly going to arrive at the end
so you say there's a take is there a
random sample exists already but it's
that that's one thing that it's kind of
hard to implement I mean there is the
whole business types you can transform
basically one type to the other one
integrand and stuff like that and or
create a date and there are a lot of SQL
functions that most of the time we're
going to compile to word from language
symbols for example now it's obviously
you can compile now to the database
equivalent I'm not sure we always have a
one-to-one representation with all the
functions and so this is I want to see
the SQL just about just one thing
regarding like the field that we missed
now that we need to decide is what
happens when we have this entity class
like things what happens when you apply
and fill list them what do the explicit
single entities that maybe a bill and
who enters those drawings or mangled is
whatever way it looks like because they
will not have anymore a first argument
that it's just a string and what does
the identifier moves like the canonical
name is it an association isn't that
what we've already had to address for
food for example i know i don't think i
think that the problem of food will kind
of go away after we have interpreted by
because in the end implicit entities or
better thought of as a granade
identities but so the thing that you're
saying is you have in what one might
call computed entities the point here is
that we don't have a pure here's an
entity it has a canonical name no I mean
three so I have two proposals that I
miss or two days ago about a name is Kim
for the fabric canonical name one is
hierarchical
it gets one with lists of lists
basically
and the other one is is actually a named
association that gets flattened every
time but there is always a unit like
these all these operation preserves the
existence of an unique identifier for
each of these tables so you can always
say oh I have created by these so now
this is the primary key the canonical
name well I lost something that for a
second there it's some I'm overdue for
eating my lunch and so on
I can we do enter the list of these
categories this what can I know no I
don't know if it works right now or on
your branch yes okay so it doesn't I
mean that the first argument is wrong
but the second argument is right I don't
know what branch you are of entity
framework actually that's what yeah it's
probably by the way to respond to a
couple of things on this live stream
somebody was talking about CSV import if
you look at the latest version 11.3 I
think CSV import is dramatically more
efficient with respect to data set and
doing large things in data set yes we're
working on improving that but the whole
point of what we're doing in this
meeting is to talk about the whole sort
of giant out of core version of what
happens with data set this is kind of
the the the out of core analog of data
set working with things that can be done
with relational databases we will have
other ones working with things that can
be done with other kinds of out of core
systems like no SQL stuff and so on but
maybe we can
sorry do we have did we figure out how
to get the actual SQL query here
first even it looks like I don't
currently have a single function that
does it because we've had we made it
through the larger refactoring and it's
not you might have within one of the
older notebooks see something already
evaluated from before yeah you should
have in Mudbox with SQL inside I'll put
something in chat and why if you can
just execute that record on your machine
or I can do that if you want I can just
share why don't you share actually have
a question which is you know with our
modern way of just being able to type a
greater than sign and then being able to
type kind of foreign language stuff
external language stuff is there any
chance that we can have people actually
type r or SQL in some way and in such a
thing I was thinking that as well yes it
will be interesting because basically we
want to expose a way that you know how
dove these schema and something to you
you are able just to get back the SQL I
mean I Pro skill system yes I already
have it but it's like I am representing
to you right now
I type SQL right now it's some utilities
and I say select for instance
well we were discussing that I have I
developed it like several years ago but
we discussed it with John fools and so
he says it can be made in stable enough
to go into production but for our
internal purposes it works pretty well
okay from title and I execute this and
here we go so just so I understand this
is an you're running an 11-3 here when
if you type a great advance on beginning
of a line greater than yeah that's a
Python cell
yeah that's a pie for service so what
would you know so the question is coming
to a similar thing as an SQL sir I mean
if you if you press the Python logo
there you'll see that has a pulldown so
right now select oh yeah you need to
select an available database so of
course you need to register the database
before and then yeah eventually we
probably can but this is highlighting
that is here right now is it's a
completely different I understand I'm
just saying in terms of what the thing
will ultimately look like the point is
if somebody is working in a notebook and
you know they say oh I just want to run
this particular SQL query they should be
able to type that SQL query into an SQL
cell and then get a result back as well
from language better yes we can do that
but we'll need some design to figure out
what will be the convenient interface
for people to switch between databases
and things yep
I understand well I mean I suspect what
will happen is that you know very soon
that thing which right now just has to
language is going to have a hundred
languages and so the interface will
change yeah when you compute external
evaluate of SQL you will also say
connect to the database I think so so
anyways kind of available even now and
we can probably make it well
highlighting a separate issue but making
sure that we have a cell like a Python
cell like connector database is
certainly possible right so the analog
just so we understand there's a UI
version of this which is the cell and
that's the external evaluate of string
version which we also need for the SQL
case yes already well then why don't we
can we merge that with external
evaluator I mean that is external
evaluator takes a language name and it
takes you know that's this notion of an
external session which is there is there
is one one one thing more about SQL that
that that basically normally you've read
the query and the data you you take it
separately now of course if you're
writing like SQL directly into a cell
you write data with the string but we
produce a query and the data is
separated and then basically is for
escaping basically to me
to make sure that people don't do miss
and again SQL injections and and so
basically you provide a template for the
query and data and and we make sure that
basically that if there is something
like drop table something it's a scale
okay let me rephrase what sure actually
that that you said that in a very
obscure way in SQL sometimes you can say
like select blah blah blah and then
where and then there is a number in
there
that number is treated as a template
slot there is discount this notion of
SQL template basically and the reason
they do that is because so that you can
only change that number and you cannot
change the rest of the query yes if
secure data and you match it with the
SQL if you like trivially you may end up
having as few injections so my only
point is that for external evaluate you
want not only the string but you also
want a separate data that you want to
provide so you provide an SQL query with
just provide everything right away
external evaluate is is being updated so
that the string it takes from the
external language contains template
string and you know slots so in other
words if you want to say you know do
something with Python using percent
right that will be trivial to do but I
wanted to show you and you were asking
about SK all generated by the queries
example is wrong you need an entity
value around it it's an abuse of
notation what you're doing there yes
that's right and teaching value and then
something like some list of properties
maybe looks very simple well it's a
simple example so in more complicated
examples you will see but generally
generally you would see our SQL pretty
close to how one would write that's
normally so there was
if basically you are doing joints and
you start doing operation with a
mutation and you're shadowing then then
the SQL gets complicated but we try to
give it as simple as possible so that
you can actually we are targeting this
SQL to particular database back-end true
or less roomm what types of things
change as we go from one back into
another certain operators have different
ways of you know writing them certain
functions will be different for
different backends are so certain
notations such as conversion to
different data types will be different
from what's data type conversions so
we're dealing with all of our standard
types including dates and things like
that yes not not all but many so I'm for
three for example some back-end
surrogate I just say that for example
days
SQLite do not implement dates at all and
so it's impossible to represent them so
if you want to have dates in SQLite you
need to represent I don't know like an
integral from 1970 or something
operations with integers or sorry reals
and so basically there are all kinds of
issues with you know that backends was
that thing in that way like timestamp
it's different so there are all kinds of
difference that that we need to get
right but I think it's a matter of
different discussion completely separate
from what we are doing right now general
okay all right so just to structure this
and then I need to go okay so one thing
I wanted to say that it's a bit a gnarly
with the woman who are amenities that
all databases support decimals and then
how we do we represent a decimal in the
what is the decimal it was like a
decimal what not it's yeah it's not be
very precision
number it's not going to set a binary
coded but it's where the where the
precision is decimal not in binary Oh
where it's where it's a decimal
number it's a certain number of decimal
digits rather than a precision as a
binary yes yes for accounting mostly yes
yes yes yes yes yes well that's a
separate discussion we should probably
have that discussion with Mark and
Robbin people yeah yeah because they
have very specific properties of you
know precision carrying like if you
multiply through the precision gets
larger well right okay fair enough
I mean that that's a specific type
you're saying in the case in these
databases
yes um
okay all right let's just like tying off
this meeting right so can we make sure
we have a complete list of the functions
that you think actually a couple of
questions so the implementations that
you have are robust at this point is
that true I mean the thing you were
showing me is a real implementation of
all this yes it is there are some some
some some issues with with with
Ephesians for now and also with times
yes
like we don't we don't yet support any
type of casting from one type to the
other if I throw you a terabyte size
database it's not there's not an issue I
mean it will just sit where he is is
actually computed on the database so yes
I mean it's just a matter of
transferring data but usually or rather
at some you were saying like usually
what you do if you have a terabyte of
data is that you first you aggregate it
several times and you perform some
operations on it is like yes what we're
doing here right so those yes all right
so but maybe one thing that we could do
is to start putting all these branches
on supposing that the build issue is
fixed we can put this stuff on the
prototype build and yeah it will also be
very nice touch they start running it
against some of our internal databases
yeah um presumably we can make the
connections and so on we have some
databases I don't know like the bugs
database what about that didn't you
really run it on it is more of a toy
implementation but I know but let's run
the real implementation it's a fairly
large database we should be able to run
it on that um yeah it's it's actually
tiny for this or the standard uh how big
is it do you know well we I was like I
think we're to be under a thousand bucks
yeah but they have quite a lot of data
associated with each one
yeah sure but it's like if you look at
the species you know far that's 1
million yeah right okay so take the
species database too but okay so so
we've got real so this
should work for real so what we're
trying to do now is to converge these
function names and semantics and so on
and we're definitely getting closer
although there's definitely some more
work to be done
I mean I'm predicting it's another
probably four hours of work um is there
any documentation that's been done yet I
think so no all right but I mean this
you know we're gonna end up with like on
the order of eight to ten functions
roughly is that true yes I mean I'm
suspicious about this entity function
thing I know that I think I probably
invented that name but I'm suspicious
about the name now any property function
is way better
okay well fine then that's that's the
easy change so you know just to
um the right um yeah okay fair enough
I'm still we still need to discuss
center naming and that will be a support
issue I mean the thing about composite
entities yeah like when you have a
single competency what how do you like
again you you let's take the content
thing like the second argument should
just be Europe or should it be continent
goes to Europe that should it refer to
it original table name sorry property
name in the original table yeah I
understand this is what you have here is
an entity constructed by a computation
and obviously it's not resolvable to a
trivial canonical name because it didn't
have one it's been computed so what we
need is just to capture you know
freeze-dry whatever that computation is
and that is you know that is the
symbolic name of the entity in some
sense yeah but there are several ways of
doing it okay so like for example if you
ever join it would be quite natural to
make it sit in the list of two elements
the left key and the right okay let me
make the comment whatever you say
whatever is the answer to an entity a
composite entity can be represented as
blah you should also just be able to
type it in right so if you say it's this
list which I don't think is gonna work
for a variety of reasons
I mean I'm suspicious about this thing
in other words it's either the
computation go ahead
no yeah what I was saying is that it's
not I mean you can type it in but there
is no guarantee there is something
existing
it corresponds to what you typed in no I
understand but that my point is if you
get to a computed entity by a
computation right then you say oh but
there's another representation of that
computer event entity my comment is
whatever that other representation is is
also a representation of the computed
entity and should be also a way to do
the computation yeah yeah yeah I
understand anything but I think that
there should be I mean even one
computation there shouldn't be more ways
of representing well fine then but then
you're already answering your question
that is the computed entity it's
representation which might be visually
presented in some different way but its
ultimate representation is full of joins
and God knows what else
yeah yeah right so then the only
question is visually if if that's the
case and the entity is is you know some
big complicated incrusted you know
symbolic representation of a computation
then the only issue is how would one
actually display that that we can make
it into an orange blob of some sort with
a place where you can see what's
happened that's what I would think which
is very similar to the food situation
right but I don't like about I think I'm
obsessed with the food situation because
I'm really hungry here okay but what I
think is that in the case of the food
situation I don't really like them but
what's a good example of this food case
yeah well what's a good what's a good
food apple
I don't know apple pie oops
apple pie with whipped cream
so I go to work come on wake up do
something why didn't that work there's
Michael here still yeah I think it
doesn't work because we don't have yeah
there is not a single ever pie with
whipped cream but how many other it did
buy for me god I see I see I see
oh my gosh well okay so what which one
referring to food for intended to return
to food intended use is that an apple a
pie and Apple as in one to be made into
a pie or some window what's that it's
really okay but any case this is what's
a good example I mean if I say chocolate
chip cookie this if you think about it
like that Michael finishes chocolate
chip cookie okay so now I press play
sir and I get all kinds of junk there I
mean I think this is the type of thing
that we'll want to do for these
composite entities yeah well if you
think about it like these things could
now be represented so what is this this
is foods aggregated by food type and
forceful type foods represented by water
aggregated by food type and a horsewhip
type and what and source food type in
this other case it's food type added
food type and variety those are
properties you have to eat at all
ok so you're saying that maybe we can
have a representation of visual
representation something like this now
one thing is that we don't need increase
identities anymore I mean we can support
them but now we have a more a better
theoretical standing on which to express
them there are single entities after an
aggregation but somebody is suggesting
that we have a future function feed food
to me yes that is exactly in the
symbolic discourse language that I'm
trying to trying to develop I'm not sure
if I we can actuate it with robotics or
anything but at least we can represent
the thought um okay in any case go ahead
um all right I think I think we're was
was anything else anybody wants to add
for this meeting
perhaps that
another meeting pretty soon yes indeed
before we forget what's going on is out
for a week
oh okay well we need we absolutely need
20 so we will have to wait okay um okay
somebody on the livestream is curious
what we're up to in machine learning as
it happens we have a machine learning
meeting that is coming up in just a few
minutes and it is possible that we might
be able to livestream that I will
investigate the same person which it
might be interested in coming into
summer school I depends who they are
which one it's hard to tell from a live
stream maybe have to know more about
people on the live stream but because
they said they were applying to careers
so ah okay well that's the summer school
is a good thing and you are you coming
this year yes and [ __ ] as well okay
cool um okay well thank you all
people in meeting and people on the live
stream and to be continued and we may in
fact do another live stream and very
shortly for a machine-learning status
meeting that we have coming up so um
thanks all see you later
Thanks okay